the 2012 cy young award winner and
five-time all-star david price on the
mound for los angeles
he's a different pitcher than what he
was in 19 he's much more of a ground
ball
machine these days david fletcher one of
the offensive leaders of the halo's
third in baseball in hits with 128
and hot of late leads things off back up
the middle backhanded by max muncie and
the throw is just a step
better than fletcher for the first out
of the night tonight's angels first
baseman phil gosselin that one up the
middle as well and therefore it wants
more is muncie two ground ball
outs kind of playing out exactly as you
described when we went on the air
tonight tom
here's upton now getting the nod in left
field tonight and on the first pitch
another ground ball
three of them make for a breezy top of
the first for the five-time all-star
24-year-old left-hander patrick sandoval
no longer a secret sandoval has
established himself as one of the
brighter
young arms in the american league
tonight making his 13th
starting assignment lead it off with the
red-hot mookie bets batting 500 since
the all-star break
here's the 3-2 and it's a basic back up
great at that by mookie so betts is
aboard to start things in the home first
and now justin turner
turner's been a problem for the angels
of late three homers in his last five
games
against the angels here at dodger
stadium that's out to right field
adele drifts over he'll play it on a
couple of hops here comes bets he's
being held
and now the throw into second on
turner's not in time
and the dodgers are in business with
nobody out in the bottom of the first
you know you could say now you're into
the dangerous part of the lineup but
that statement applies to the entire
dodger lineup here's max muncie got him
with it
first strikeout for sandoval how good is
that slider
they're 3 34 against that pitch
the 10-time all-star three-time mvp
facing the
old uniform for the first time since the
angels made the decision to
release him back in may second and third
with one gun i'm a roller
and mayfield's going to concede the run
for the out
and betts is hobbling doesn't seem to be
a lot of concern in there though
no there's smiles turner advanced to
third on the back end of the play
and now it's the former world series mvp
corey seeger
mayfield is there to make the catch and
that retires the side
could have been a lot worse second and
third with nobody out
max dassey leads things off in the
angels half of ending number two against
david price
who got through the angels in order with
three ground balls to start his night he
had a call strike three taken by stassi
here's joe adele and adele is rung up on
an o2 fastball
yeah that's that backdoor cutter i mean
he kind of chewed up the young
adele right there two gone now for jose
iglesias the shortstop the veteran
iglesias sends a drive out to center
routine play for
taylor and the site is retired chris
taylor leading things off in the second
taylor followed by a.j pollock and
austin barnes in a full count
swing and miss on a fastball to taylor
leading off the second
back-to-back strikeouts for patrick
sandoval david price back to work
can't ask for a better start six up six
down
all six batters he's faced he has issued
strike one two mayfield sends a ground
ball to third
go down quickly and quietly for a third
straight inning david price perfect
through
three at home tonight first and second
with two away
two on two out now for corey seeger
seeger pops it up
mayfield is under it to retire the side
in the third david price off to a
terrific start nine up nine down
nine of nine in first pitch strikes
tonight
david fletcher looking for a strike
sends a ball to deep center field taylor
on the run and it bounds up over the
wall
it'll be a ground rule double for
fletcher leading off the angels fourth
and a throw into second base is in time
to catch fletcher
folks you just don't see that a lot in
the course of a major league season the
player getting picked off second base
there's ball four to pollock he has now
reached base in a career-best
23 in a row two gone now for david price
we're batting with the man on and two
away bryce lines that into right
it checks up in front of the dell and
it's a base hit for david price
that is a very good swing you talk about
getting on top of a fastball
career hit number six for david price
and now it's bets with two men on bets
is singled and scored
and grounded at first base tonight a
base hit into left field
pollux being waved around to score and
it's two nothing dodgers
two-nothing leap for david price and
he'll go back to work against the angels
in the fifth jose iglesias lifts off
that one's hit well out to
left and that one's gone
number eight for iglesias and it's a two
to one
dodger lead chris taylor now with the
runner at second and two gone
only three strikeouts so far here we go
on three and two again a fastball got
him looking
[Applause]
when they think you're going to zag
david price continuing for a
sixth inning of work making a bid for
his longest start of the year
and here's the number nine hitter jack
mayfield six homers
in his last 16 games there's a drive out
to center field and well hit
on cue jack mayfield has
tied it anthony who it's gonna be off
for david price
what a spot for the rookie right-hander
austin warren
facing a future hall of famer here in a
tie game
with the go-ahead run at first base and
two out in the seventh
albert batting 182 against right-handers
with an er
rather an ops of 500 and that all works
out for the angels
as a couple of young relievers keep the
dodgers quiet in the seventh
gosselin's been held hitless tonight
breaking ball
[Music]
yeah got him on three in a row
gonna have a pinch hitter here for the
dodgers as will smith has grabbed the
bat
go ahead run aboard with two out smith
slugs a
fly ball out to shallow left
upped and gloves it to retire the side
dave roberts had to make a move for his
right fielder
as mookie betts was removed a couple of
innings ago
right hip discomfort for mookie bets
certainly not good news for the dodgers
to the bottom of the ninth inning
exciting stuff here in a 2-2
game and trey turner making his
dodger debut the 0-1 pitch has popped up
one gun with jose blasius setting the
table has never been more important
that's into right field
adele will score the angels have taken
their first lead of the game
and shohei ohtani is the announced pinch
hitter he's not going to hit
crowd doesn't like it you want to see
him taking that bat right no doubt the
angels have pushed across the go ahead
score
and the first pitch to mayfield is
hitting the air out to shallow right
field
muncie can't find the handle on it
iglesias scores
two runs in the inning here's corey
seeger now he's been quiet tonight
fastball up that's hit well out to
center field
marsh signaling he's got it he's got it
at the wall that's gonna be enough to
tag and score a run
and it's a 4-3 angels lead
cunning and winning runs on base two
gone in the 10th iglesias a strike away
pollock sets it on the ground for
mayfield who wins the race to third base
and the angels survive what a finish